the raiders haven't been to the super
bowl since 2002 that was the last year
the buccaneers won it before this year
here is john gruden complaining about
the failures of his defense to step up
when the games matter the
most we've got to play better uh
complimentary football our defense has
got to get some critical stops at the
end of the game
mahomes beat us at the buzzer in vegas
uh the dolphins beat us at the buzzer
and uh
justin herbert and the chargers beat us
at the buzzer we've got to improve our
fourth quarter pass rush we got to
finish games with our defense and
preserve a lead that's something we're
going to continue to work on i'm telling
you i'm sick of these zoom meetings i'll
tell you that you want to grab some of
these raider feds and
you want them in that allegiance stadium
we missed them you know don't tell me
their presence would would have mattered
in the fourth quarter against miami or
the chargers or the chiefs
we need that noise we need that energy
our players feed off it i feed off it
stay with us and uh pretty i appreciate
your criticism
and uh can't wait to get out in the
community and see all you guys again
soon let's beat this virus
sure sure
yeah sure he appreciates the criticism i
you know i think when you see gruden
with that raised eyebrow constantly i
really do think he is the one kid whose
mother said your face is gonna freeze
that way one of these days and it did
like that it's already it's pretty
amazing he can do it i mean you know
it's it's part of him that when i think
of john gruden i think of him
you know in the quarterback room
teaching us offense
and making you know oddly enough he was
the first snarky guy i ever worked with
all right or you know in snarky comments
snarky comment there's no paste and copy
but a snarky comment and that eyebrow
certainly will always be etched in my
brain forever certainly but but but his
his point is real
i mean the raiders it is all defense
holy crap bola batman i mean there's
nothing on their front seven it's gotta
start there to what he is talking about
a little bit they get nothing out of
their pass rush really max crosby is
their best pass rusher he's
he's real good he's not great or
anything like that i'm not gonna put him
in super stardom but there's no
you know disruptor difference maker in
the whole front seven there's none of
that and then in the back end there's a
little talent but they're young and
undisciplined and a little crazy that
way too so that doesn't work well okay
young and undisciplined in the back end
and nobody does anything to make a play
in the front end i can tell you you're
going to be one of the the bottom five
defenses in football if that's your
formula i don't care what team you are
and that's where they got to adjust and
of course there that graphic kind of
proves the point
how much of its personnel how much of
its coaching though paul gunther got
thrown under the bus by john gruden
during the season sure the defense
wasn't good enough if you're not
committing the resources to the defense
in a smart way yes and let's face it
john gruden's in charge of that
franchise john gruden's an offensive guy
right he's going to skew toward boosting
the offense
it all roads lead back to the guy who's
in charge of the team and it's gruden
either he hired the wrong defensive
staff or he didn't put enough money into
the right people to come in and play
defense but it's on him and this is one
of the problems when a guy who's an
offense only guru ends up in charge of a
full team well yes you know but that's
that's status quo for a lot of those
type of coaches usually you see
defensive coaches they try to go in all
in on defense because that's how they
got the job and they want to make sure
hey the fan base they expect defense i
got that same with the offense but a lot
of those guys don't run the team so
that's the deal i got you you're exactly
right you know he he set it up here
early on to get the offense stabilized
they got one of the best offensive lines
in football we know they got josh jacobs
and running back they got a damn good
receiving core and they probably got the
third best tight end in all of football
behind kittle and and kelsey so with
that they don't need to do much on that
side of the ball you're right it's about
the personnel to me on the defensive
side of the ball uh you know paul
gunther okay yeah he's not you know he's
not you know uh rex ryan or not rex ryan
who's his dad i was going to say his dad
and i'm blanking on his name who's rex
ryan's dad uh buddy ryan damn buddy i
mean he only beat the crap out of my dad
historian uh historian knows all history
except his own and buddy ryan yes those
are the two exceptions but but either
way no i think
the point is what you made the talent
there
is not good enough no matter who the
coach is and they did i think mayok and
gruden they worked on the offense and
now it's got to be an off season of we
got to spend money resources on making
this defense
better not that it has to be the best in
football but it's certainly if they can
get to the middle part of football
around 15 or 16 then i would go okay
watch out for the raiders they're going
to be in the playoffs and they might be
a pain in the butt
yeah look this is a team that has
this feel this vibe of
gradual improvement they still haven't
been to the playoffs three straight
years since gruden has returned and as i
said and i stand by it any other coach
would have been on the hot seat any
other coach would be on a blazing
hot seat going into this season gruden
hey he's just he's just in year four of
year 10 which could end up being year 15
because mark davis does not seem
inclined to do anything about it and
that's fine it's great work if you can
get it but the reality is at some point
they got to be on a trajectory that
takes them to the post season with seven
of those spots now in the afc or this
gruden return to the nfl gets deemed a
failure this is a huge three
through three years it's a failure
it's pass fail playoffs are not it's
pass fail and that f gets bigger when
you have seven spots in each conference
and yeah i think this is huge if he goes
0 for four with the raiders getting to
the postseason when he had a team that
was just in the playoffs a year before
he got there that that is a huge
indictment of john gruden's current
coaching skills and he may not like
hearing that but it's the truth well i
think he went into the job and probably
sold the ownership
that listen we're going to you didn't
have to sell anything well you didn't
have to sell anything he was he had the
job they had him at hello before hello
and i got that listen hey we we talk
about the raiders a lot john gruden is a
a lightning rod of a subject i mean the
raiders are more relevant with john
gruden
at that coach there's no doubt about
that certainly you know they
unfortunately you know antonio brown
went you know
kind of crazy on them there that ruined
some of their plans to a degree all
right the khalil mack issue and lack of
cash
and being able to spend him forced them
to trade you know their best defensive
player to a degree so uh i think that
mark davis
and john gruden at least sold to him
after he got the job that listen if you
want me to do this i got to build this
my way and it might take two or three
years you know we're seeing a lot of
coaches demand those six-year contracts
and all that well he's a super bowl
winning quarterback that i mean coach
that you know has history there and they
gave him 10 years but to you to what
you're saying it is a huge year and this
is the year you go year four in the nfl
okay you know you've done some good
things but now it's time to produce like
you're talking about and if he doesn't
get to the playoffs uh his his butt will
be i think extremely hot
i think the six year contract has become
the anti-dysfunction
movement by a team i hear you
just you know hey i need to give you six
years you want six years because we've
had this revolving door this is our way
to prove to you to everyone else and to
ourselves that we're not going to fire
you after two or three the 10-year deal
for john gruden was different that was a
vegas move that was a we finally got
john gruden back i've wanted him for
years i got him back and i'm committing
to him for 10 years even though i don't
believe the full 10 years is guaranteed
and i think once he gets past year five
to the extent that mark davis would be
inclined to apply that hot seat it would
be easier to get away from some of that
money on the back end it was explained
to me when the deal was done it's not a
firm 10-year 100 million dollar
commitment with full guarantees all the
way through but uh at some point at some
point mark davis has to ask himself is
this where we want to be and it may just
be look it
hey
every team says we want to win the super
bowl the reality is you win at the box
office you win on the balance sheet and
having john gruden with the raiders you
know they went through a lot of lean
ugly years
uh where they weren't winning and they
weren't relevant now regardless of
whether or not they make it to the
playoffs they're relevant every year yes
they're interesting every year john
gruden brings that that appeal to the
team
that is independent of wins and losses
and you know fans don't like to hear
this they get caught up in wins and
losses in the pursuit of a championship
but this is ultimately an entertainment
business and you need to be entertaining
and the raiders are entertaining they
may not be a playoff team but they're
entertaining uh yeah they are there's no
doubt uh but this is where you know i'm
gonna vouch for my old head coach here
trust me
he's going crazy he wants to be in the
playoffs he wants to win a super bowl he
he is not there just to make a show and
sell tickets and you know i don't know
mike mayok real well but i know him
enough to know you know
he's doing all he can too he's he's a
real worker a real football guy they're
trying to do this the right way and
added on to that i'm gonna make one more
thing where
hey they got gus bradley as their
defensive coordinator i think that's
gonna improve their football team i
really do gus was in tampa with john and
i back in those days he's one of the
better defensive minds in football and i
think that's going to make them better
just off the bat right off the bat right
there to have him on that side of the
ball certainly but yes as we talked
about they need help on that side of the
ball and that's where mayok and gruden
are going to have to help out gus
bradley a little bit just to give him a
little talent to make his defense really
go
well if there is fairness and
consistency in the nfl the raiders and
mayok will have one fewer draft pick as
a result of john gruden's open
flirtation with richard sherman that
blatant example of tampering from a few
weeks what did he what you you were just
at him what do you would he what did he
do to you what did he think nothing okay
i don't know i thought maybe you know i
did he beat you up for the last owners
meeting or something what happened
no i he no uh
uh i i feel like the guys that hate me
the most are the guys that i am the most
likely uh-huh uh-huh and i do too snarky
comment space comment
whether it's gruden
whether it's aaron rodgers right right
and and and i'm that kid yelling you're
a free agent you're a free agent you're
about to be poor you're about to be poor
that's me but at the end of the day i
think i think we're we're we're exactly
alike
that drives them crazy i don't disagree
because i can see through them i know
what makes them tick there's definitely
some things there that are very similar
there's no doubt about it that's why i
laugh and joke about it certainly and
hey but i'll say this i have been to a
playoff game in the last three years oh
you're such a jerk yeah you're such a
jerk you know yeah he's he's he's great
he's he's gotten derek carr wired derek
carr played phenomenal football last
year listen is he a superstar no but
derek carr played really well last year
they got that offense in place he really
is but you know what he'd say to you one
of the things he first said to me you
know when i used to you know mess up
those plays you see on social media
where i just careful careful
i am i don't it's not no four letter
words or anything you know when when i
would mess up you know west right f left
372 y stick z spot and you know he'd
test me in the in the meetings in front
of people hey sam spit it out you know
what's right he saw somebody do these
bingo use split candidate 58 lexus and
i'd be
oh you know sims
you know in his eye i can't do that eye
thing you know
you know what you're like you're like
warm pee running down my leg you know
that was on the first thing he said that
wasn't that bad it's 20 21 warm pea down
your leg that's what he said
[Laughter]
that is one area where he and i are
definitely not alike i can
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports